all right good people of the Internet
I'm live it's 8:45 a.m. Pacific 11:45
a.m. Eastern and we're doing our weekly
direct messages which I'm now doing
every Monday and Wednesday just kind of
getting you guys caught up on things
sharing a little information just trying
to make a little sense of the madness
which the madness does continue I hope
everybody had a good weekend
not that week's end anymore it's sort of
a weak day into the weekend and
everything's sort of the same I know
it's getting harder for everybody to
shut down and disconnect and all of
those things and you know I try to take
these weekends off at least off the grid
or off social media not a you know
television or whatever television - but
does anyone watch television anymore I
actually flipped the channels yesterday
and I was like man this feels so old to
me right now but it is getting harder to
tell between the Monday Friday thing and
then the weekend thing it's all sort of
blurring together and I just think
everyone's sort of a little nutty right
now I'm sensing that we've gone from
like five weeks where like we were sort
of seeing better angels and now people
are starting to get frustrated and I
understand the frustration and you know
we're seeing a lot of crazy nonsense
from our elected officials that would
warrant people not being that happy the
governor of Michigan you guys probably
saw this she there is a video of her I
shared it on Twitter that's going viral
it has millions of views where she's
talking about how people should not be
allowed to landscape or plant seeds
right now what right does the governor
have to tell you if you can plant seeds
or landscape on your own property
now she said well it's it's snowing at
anyway and it's cold so you wouldn't be
planting but it's a moot point also
I'm a very novice gardener but I do know
that you start seeds indoors usually
we're starting seeds indoors here right
now and it's a lot warmer here in
California so there's that kind of
nonsense and then you guys may have seen
the viral video of the the Venice skate
park which they took a bulldozer and
they just pushed sand into instead of
just maybe taking a piece of yellow tape
and
putting it around the thing or
stationing one police officer there or
something like that they've destroyed it
too just decided to destroy the Venice
skate park which is completely an iconic
thing for mostly for young people all
over the world it's really just like
we're watching this authoritarian creep
and then de Blasio did you see that
video at de Blasio get your camera start
snapping pictures of people and we'll
send law enforcement and then here in
Los Angeles Eric Garcetti you know if
you see someone doing something you
better report on them
we've just got like a lot of weird
forces at work right now and I don't
think you know this is an interesting
thing when you when you talk about all
these things at once it sort of sounds
like it's a conspiracy like these people
have gotten together to take all our
rights and all that thing I don't think
that's exactly true like I don't think
whoever ordered the bulldozer at the
venice thing was connected to de Blasio
directly or connected to Eric Garcetti
or the governor of Michigan but what
we're seeing is in times of crisis you
see people that love power start
exercising power and what I'm really
worried about is the more that we stay
at home the more that we just sort of
forget oh dude we used to go to skate
parks did we used to go visit grandma
because over time the new normal just
becomes the new normal and then and then
that's it so you know so in the last
couple weeks what we've started to see
in the last week really is that there
are protests throughout the country and
people are out there saying we want to
get back to work and you know what what
works or doesn't work in New York City
is very different than what might work
or not work in Montana and people are
expressing their rights and of course
most of mainstream media and the blue
check Twitterati and the celebrities and
comedians of Twitter are just mocking
these people is backwards Tea Party
buffoons and all that these are people
who I think whether whether they know
everything about the science or not and
we can again debate all of the stuff
about quash in the you know flattening
the curve and all of those things and by
the way I have been practicing social
distancing and the six-foot thing and
I've only been out of the house maybe
twice in the last three four weeks
something like that but it is good when
we have a little pushback on encroaching
authoritarianism so
I want to I want to tell you a couple of
the things that are going on right now
that are interesting because it's
happening worldwide in Brazil thousands
have hit the streets in rio de janeiro
and san paulo to protest in germany
there's been hundreds of people gathered
in parks Huntington Beach
there's an event called March for
freedom which took place with more than
two hundred protesters in Nevada there
were residents gathering at the State
Capitol San Diego had over 100
protesters gathered downtown and
Michigan had thousands of protesters in
cars and on foot to demand that the
state real but look none of these things
are inherently bad I just want you to
understand that these people are trying
to figure out what to do trying to get
their lives going you know and there's
some point where no matter what the
numbers say we do have to have an honest
conversation about public health versus
eventually just keeping us all in this
economic crushing and more than economic
crashing this like life crushing
situation that we're in we may have to
reopen and risk some sickness and some
death that's just a sad fact and the
people that say no we just have to stay
in forever till it's completely gone
into Oh everyone has antibodies until
there's a cure and all this up it's a
it's a lie and it's nonsense and and
more than that it's really just them
expressing oh just behave the way we
want you to and by the way it's it's
always coming from you know there's a
high correlation right now between the
people that keep getting everything
wrong about Ukraine and Russia and net
neutrality and all of these things that
the world is gonna end right we hear all
these stories the world's gonna end
we kill Soleimani World War three is
gonna begin all these things about the
people that ramp everything up all the
time they're the ones also that are
trying to keep everybody absolutely at
home right now we have to figure this
out and it has to be done by the way
with a blend the way the the way it was
supposed to work with that constitution
thing with the blend between the states
and the federal government and I think
we're seeing some version from that
version of that you guys may have seen
Nancy Pelosi from San Francisco boy that
lady with her I think she's worth like
20 million bucks she did James Corden's
show not that anyone's watching that and
she stood there and try
her two freezers refrigerator giant
stainless steel freezer refrigerators
they're about 25 grand each I'm sure
that those are not the only ones in her
house and she opens up the the bottom
drawer her freezer drawer and what do
you see it's stacked with ice cream now
and it's extremely expensive ice cream
and all that now we do have ice cream
cookies cookie sandwiches here we do I
got I can get six of them for like 350
or something so I don't want to say that
I'm above her in the world of ice cream
I do love ice cream I miss ice cream but
you know when this whole thing happened
when we started stocking our fridge and
we got a we got a separate little fridge
everything that we have in this house is
to survive we have a ton of meat we have
a ton of chicken we have a ton of rice
ton of pasta all the basic stuff I
remember the first when we first went
out I wanted to get more ice cream
David's like you can't waste space in
the freezer for ice cream so watching
these out-of-touch politicians do this
kind of thing it's just awful she had a
large stockpile yeah her fridges are
24,000 dollars each her house is seven
point five million dollars again I I
don't begrudge her that well I sort of
begrudge her that because she's used her
political power to make money but i but
and her ice cream is $13 a pint $13 a
pint really think about that 22 million
Americans are filing for unemployment
right now so how you doing Nancy okay I
wanted to also touch on one other thing
because remember that that paper the
gray lady
it was it's the paper formerly known as
the New York Times which as most of you
are seeing has been just completely
exposed that's an absolute lying sack of
[ __ ] propaganda operation it really has
just absolutely if you've watched it
over the last couple years hit pieces on
many of the people I know hit pieces on
me just dishonest drivel from what's
supposed to be the paper of record right
they had a really fascinating piece that
blamed Fox News for a guy's death who
got coronavirus and went on a cruise
right and I want to read this to you
this is this is just incredible this is
actually from The Times piece okay on
March 1st Joe Joyce and his wife Jan
Jane set sail for Spain
Kruse first flying to Florida his adult
children Kevin Eddie and Kristen miter
suggested that that the impending doom
of the corona virus made this bad idea
Jo Joyce was 74 a nonsmoker healthy four
years after he opened his bar he stopped
drinking completely he didn't see the
problem he watched he watched Fox and
believed it was under control Kristen
told me early in March Sean Hannity went
on-air proclaiming that he didn't like
the way the American people were getting
scared unnecessarily he saw it all and
and said he saw it all he said as like
let's bludgeon Trump with this new hoax
now do you see what they did there on
March 1st
on March 1st they set sail they took the
cruise and then what do they sort of
bury beneath that early in March Sean
Hannity went on-air okay so you see what
they're doing they're writing a story to
fit this idea that on March 1st this guy
went on the cruise because of what sean
hannity said on fox news but that didn't
happen till after and of course they put
this up there'll be no retraction nobody
will get fired I mean this is what they
do over and over the best part of this
on February 27th just three days before
the piece was written the author of the
piece Gina
Belafonte wrote tweeted she tweeted out
I fundamentally don't understand this
panic incidents of the disease is
declining in China virus is not deadly
in vast majority of cases production and
so on will slow down and we'll obviously
rebound so the author of the piece was
downplaying this On February 27th the
guy takes a cruise on the first Hannity
says saying after he's on the cruise and
then they blame Hannity and Fox News for
the guy's debt this is the type of
propaganda that we must all be fighting
and by the way one of the things that
I'm probably more concerned I actually
am more concerned about this then than
the virus itself is that we had a big
problem a big tech I think you all know
that problem right whether you get
YouTube videos in your feed that you're
subscribed to or whether you see
people's tweets that you follow all of
this stuff right that we know that
they're manipulating us and they've been
doing it and then there was this debate
for like a year should the government
get involved yes or no it's clearly too
late for that
but just today I saw that Facebook is
banning groups that are trying to
arrange protests so the so Facebook is
now acting as a government agency and we
have no doubt that this is happening on
on YouTube and Twitter and everywhere
else so this is this is deeply deeply
dangerous especially because as I keep
telling you guys I don't know if you
know this but there's an election coming
up and they might start quashing some
voices that they don't want before then
you clear out the brush you keep doing
it as it gets closer and closer to the
election so there's just like some weird
stuff happening right now I am still
hopeful though because I do think that
the American spirit basically is what
can break us through this thing I think
that people actually are starting to
understand things that maybe we weren't
thinking about like I talk about this
all the time but the average mainstream
person has not thought about states
rights in a long time right why states
should have different decision-making
capabilities over their citizens or
their citizens should actually have it
over their government people are
actually talking about that now
so that's actually very cool by the way
that's something that I write about
quite extensively and don't burn this
book which finally comes out next week
one week from tomorrow you can get your
copy you can pre-order it don't burn
this book com or you go to Amazon or
Barnes and noble.com etc etc and by the
way everyone that pre-orders the book
tomorrow we are releasing we flipped the
script this weekend we flipped the
script and my husband David interviewed
me we talked about a bunch of stuff that
we haven't talked about publicly before
it was complete flip and fun and
pleasant and interesting and different
and if you preorder the book tomorrow
we're gonna post a link where you just
put in your order confirmation number
and you will get that video so you can
go to don't burn this book com2 to
preorder that and i want to jump to a
couple questions chris so we only take
questions by the way on the reuben
report community which you can sign up
get all our videos early and ad free at
Reuben report.com
Chris asks did you watch the new MJ
Michael Jordan documentary the last
dance
either way LeBron or Jordan so I didn't
see it last night I'm sure I will see it
I saw a gajillion people talking about
it those were my prime like love of
basketball
years actually even now when I do cardio
I watch old 80s 90s basketball games so
I loved loved loved those years
Jordan is by far the best player to ever
pick up a basketball I don't even think
it's comparable to LeBron and you can
look at the numbers you can look at the
scoring bah bah bah but what I would say
is this that Jordan systematically took
out everybody right 1990 he takes out
well ninety he the Pistons beat him but
the next year he takes out Isaiah the
next year he takes out magic the next
year he takes out Drexler the next year
he takes out Berkeley the next year he
takes out Kemp and Payton the next two
years he takes out Malone and Stockton
it's like he just assassinated all of
the guys in front of him that is what a
true winner is he was in the final six
times he won six championships so bran
is something like what four for ten or
something crazy like that anyway that's
just a little something there
oh my doc this is extremely weird my
document has suddenly shifted to like a
matrix like font I don't know if you
guys could see this right there but it
looks like I'm in the matrix right now
so I don't know what these questions are
saying David you can text me some of the
questions but in the meantime or Michael
you can text me some of the questions in
the meantime I'll just keep rolling here
let's see yeah I can't see anything look
at that that is very weird isn't it
hey you know you talk about big tech
next thing you know your Google Doc
turns into matrix font I don't know what
that's about
lordy Lordy let me have a little sip of
coffee here so I think related to the to
the protests I think this is the
situation that we're in okay my guys are
texting me some questions I think this
is really the situation we're in we have
to figure out how to do this right like
how much longer can we do this so here
in Los Angeles for example we've got a
May 15th they're taught us to stay home
until May 15 now that's still that's
still over two weeks away it's like two
and a half three weeks away right now
now it's not as if the day May 15th
rolls around that suddenly we reopen
everything and it's and even if we did
let's let's even pretend we magically
did like we know it's not going to be
that way but May 15th runs around now
now everything's open and again we know
it won't be it's going to be some teared
version of it restaurant
we'll have a certain amount of seats
that won't be in there anymore people
will also be nervous to go out you don't
just get it all going at once we're
gonna phase this thing in and what that
means is that when we say May 15th we
really do we really mean June 15th like
what happens by the summer etc etc so we
really have to figure this out and
figure out how to help local businesses
I mean it's been actually kind of nice
that we haven't gone to restaurants in a
while because we're cooking the hell out
of this and David's a great chef and
I've gotten pretty good on the barbecue
but like there are restaurants that will
need us there are small stores that will
need us like think of think of in your
town what your mom-and-pop operations or
just think of your local strip mall all
right you're a little local I'm not even
talking about the big malls although
even think about that it was think about
it this weekend like the idea of after
this going to a giant mall where there's
just tons of people and stores and DEP
that up that I that feels kind of weird
but even think about your local strip
mall like we've got a little strip mall
in walking distance from my house a
couple like kind of downtrodden stores
actually I keep praying that a Starbucks
will open there because when the
Starbucks comes to a strip mall
everything kind of wakes up but I'm
pretty sure they've all been closed in
these lat in the last month and I'm
pretty sure none of them are reopening
so that means about two blocks from my
house we're just gonna have this empty
strip mall so we've really got to figure
out like this is gonna change real
estate this is gonna change patterns of
where people live I think a ton of
people are gonna realize that they
actually really do like working from
home and maybe you're gonna have to
change their lives accordingly because
we all can't work out of our kitchens so
there's there's just so much that's
that's flipping okay let's see here I
got they sent me the questions let me
see what's going on here any at-home
exercise tips for those of us with no
gym access and no equipment and he's
gonna sneak another one in here what's
your favorite kind of coffee so coffee
wise so I always tell you guys I do the
French press I get the whole beans I
grind them do it every morning first
thing I do after a glass of water and
taking Clyde out to pee Clyde how you
doing what am i drinking right now this
morning I opened up a Pete's coffee
major Dickinson blend which I like I
usually like darker sort of bigger
bolder flavors sort of how I like red
wine too I usually like cabs
so that's what I'm doing right now I was
doing some bulletproof coffee a couple
weeks ago I try to mix it up actually
usually when I go to the coffee but when
I go to the supermarket I'm just looking
at all the coffee's I try to just like
pick some different ones so that I'm
always kind of testing and like
sometimes I mix a couple together and
the the other question was about working
out so we do have an elliptical machine
here so I did do the elliptical
yesterday while watching the Golden
Girls which is on every Sunday on TV
lands from 7:00 a.m. to 5:00 p.m. so I
did about an hour cardio while doing
that I mean I think I know this sounds
simple about like take walks like one of
the things that's actually been nice is
seeing the amount of people in the
streets that are just getting outside
like humans have like a desire to
actually sit outside be outside talk and
and see each other and all those things
so I think one little thing is if you
don't have anything in your house well
first of you can do push-ups right like
I try to do a decent amount of amount of
push-ups so you can do push-ups you can
figure out some like simple resistance
things you know like using your bed or
like the you know like the edge of your
the your bed whatever that is you can
find you know figure out some things to
do but also I mean just go on Amazon and
you can probably I'm guessing for 20
bucks you can get like a couple like
simple dumbbells and just like I mean
jump on YouTube have you been on that
thing there's a lot of videos on there
and just find some simple things that
you can do but I would say walking if
you got nothing nothing else just walk
and just basically you know one of the
things I'm interested in when we see
this at the end when we see all the
post-mortems of how everyone survives or
didn't survive Korona I think it's gonna
be interesting to see all the articles
on Americans got 3.4% fatter or you know
or Americans got 4.6% slimmer or some
something and I think for people with
their heads on straight which is why
when I've been doing these videos like
so consistently I talked about Jordan
Peterson's 12 rules for life and I'm
just interested in people that are sort
of setting their world in order right
now like we've had an opportunity over
these last five six weeks to eat right
to eat more at home to not eat as much
fast food - a lot of people are drinking
more I mean
sign points to drinking more and we've
been having probably a glass or maybe
two glasses of wine at night something
like that I haven't no that I've been
drunk really well we did have one night
we did have margaritas and I think I was
actually drunk but like I haven't been
drunk really really been trying to eat
right and exercise right I also knew
that you know I've got the book coming
out next week and I wanted to sort of be
and be in good physical shape so I'm
pretty much in the lowest weight I've
been in in in a long time I really
wanted a haircut before the book tour
but now I'm doing the entire book tour
from here which still I'd still like if
this area was a little more just link
the sides like a little tighter you know
I mean but we're all dealing with what
we got to deal with so there you go
anyways we are doing these every Monday
and Wednesday so don't forget join us at
Ruben report comm where you get early
access to our videos and add free video
we put up our interview with Marco Rubio
this morning which was actually super
interesting and one of the things he
talks about it's a kind of short
interview actually because he was doing
a million things he is a senator and
we're in the midst of a crisis but one
of the things that's most interesting
that he talks about is he actually does
care about states rights and the blend
between what his state Florida can do
versus what the federal government can
do and he talks about what it's been
like to fight to get more bids small
business loans and all sorts of stuff
like that and actually literally as I
was interviewing him about a half hour
before that we got emailed or was it an
email we got a call actually for my
business manager that we were we were
okayed for one of the business loans
which is great because we hired somebody
new Michael in our in the midst of this
whole thing and we're trying to expand
and we gave our guys a little bonus this
weekend too because everybody's busting
their butts so I think there are some
good things happening as always Rubin
report calm for that ad free video an
early video and don't burn this book
ladles and jelly spoons it comes out a
week from tomorrow finally and I think
what I'm most proud of really truly is
that the ideas that I presented in this
book which I finished writing last
summer I mean publishing just takes a
really really really long time I
finished writing it last summer we
edited it in the fall and now we're
finally in the spring of 2020 but the
ideas that I
in this book are more relevant right
this second because of Corona even
though I had no idea that coronavirus
was happening nor did anyone else right
and I love that I love that because I
was trying to write something timeless
and I think what you'll see that I
present in this book about states rights
about about guns about democracy about
the West about time-tested ideals that
have been churned over generations to
make America the freest place on earth I
think it has more value now than ever
because we're finding that suddenly we
can't go to skate parks and we have
governors that don't want us to plant
seeds so we've got some of the answers
don't burn this book calm all right guys
it's Monday have a great week everybody
and I'll talk to you on Wednesday
[Music]